[موسيقى]
تم بناء هذه القلعة السريالية على
أنقاض قلعة من القرون الوسطى من قبل رجل فضولي للغاية
[موسيقى]
يقع صاروخ أماتي في
جبال الألب الشمالية بإيطاليا ، وقد بدأ البناء في
عام 1850 بتكليف من الكونتيسة
سيزار ماتي الذي كان يدرس نفسه بنفسه
المخترع وغريب الأطوار تمامًا
كان نيته أن تكون هذه القلعة
موطن ثورته الطبية ، وهو مفهوم
يعتمد على استخدام طاقة النباتات
لعلاج الأمراض الجسدية
، تنعكس حساسيته الانتقائية في
تصميم المتاهة
للغرف المتصلة عشوائيًا مات ماتي في 87  عامًا ،
لكنه لم يذهب بعيدًا ، فقد دُفن في
الكنيسة المزينة بشكل متقن
كنسخة متماثلة من كوردوبا مسكيتا في
إسبانيا على مدار العشرين عامًا الأخيرة من
حياته ولم يغادر القلعة مطلقًا وبعد
وفاته تم التخلي عنها حتى
عام 2005  عندما استولت مجموعة مستقلة على
الموقع وأعادت فتحه مرة
أخرى للجمهور لاستكشاف هذا
السكن غير المعتاد
[موسيقى]